I have to go with "The Godfather."
Mr. Al Pacino.
When he kills the Chief of Police.
Oh man, there's so many, there's so many this year even.
"Goodfellas."
"Paper Moon."
"Chitty, Chitty, Bang, Bang."
Viola Davis in "Doubt."
"Network."
My favorite movie of all time is "Network."
"I'm just mad as hell and I'm not gonna take it anymore."
It was just a revelation.
"You think I'm funny? You think I'm a clown?"
I think that scene is amazing.
"Wizard of Oz."
"Dr. Strangelove."
"Laura" by Otto Preminger.
"The Sound of Music."
"Snow White."
Christopher Plummer singing.
I fell in love with him and I've been in love with him ever since and the movie, so.
"A Hard Day's Night" and my sister nudging me...
...because I was singing too loud along with the songs.
It's the first time I saw "E.T."
I think Kevin Kline in "In and Out".
I wanted him, I wanted E.T.
Marlon Brando of course changed everything.
That was kind of a beginning for me of my love affair with movies...
...and me wanting to be a part of that wonder.